As everybody knows, Santa Claus lives in the
North Pole.
More specifically, in the Svalbard archipielago,
where there
is the northernmost human settlement. Svalbard
is the only
place on Earth where you don´t need a visa
to enter.
However, their 2600 habitants must be self-sufficient
and
carry a gun anytime they leave the main town.
This is
because of the polar bears population, who
might tear your
body apart with no mercy if they find you
unarmed. But,
over all, Svalbard, which belongs to the Kingdom
of
Norway, is the hotspot of a political dispute
with Russia.
Yes, this frozen paradise has pretty good
chances to
become the new Dubai. They have one of the
bigges oil
beds in the world. And even more! They are
the Gateway to
the Artic route, a new commercial route that
might become
one of the most important ways for the international
trade.
This is why Svalbard is more than another
territorial dispute.
We are talking about a new cold war involving
the United
States, Canada and even China. Today, we will
tell you the
story.
Imagine a land with open doors for immigrants,
no matter
where do they come from. A place where military
presence
is forbidden because it´s a demilitarized
zone. A fiscal
haven with the average salary of Norway. Well…
this place
exists and it´s called SVALBARD. And yes,
it is in the North
Pole. If you go to Svalbard, there is no need
to worry about
catching a cold or a flu: the extremely cold
temperatures
make it impossible for virus and bacterias
to stay here.
And, by the way, in their capital, LONGYEARBYEN,
is
where you can find the world´s biggest liquor
collection.
Just like that. If you wanna try a cognac
from the 19 th
century or a rare and exclusive whisky, Karlsberger
Pub is
the place to go. Let me introduce you to their
owner, Steve
Dorfssen.
At
the beginning of the XX Century, Svalbard
was a no
man´s land and only some whale fishermen
would dare to
go through the place. Nonetheless, after the
First World
War, almost all the countries signed the Svalbard
Treaty.
There it´s written that Norway holds the
sovereignity over
the territory… But with some restrictions!
Basically,
Norwegian government is banned to put any
ban. They
can´t send their army, nor build any headquarter
or
stronghold. And they must allow every citizen
or company,
no matter where are they from, to enter the
islands and
exploit their natural resources. And this
is how two cities
where born.
On one hand we have LONGYEARBYEN, where the
majority of the population is Norwegian. On
the other hand
there is BARENTSBURG, with a Russian majority.
In both
cases, they started as coal-miners settlements.
And now you might wonder Where do the mining
companies pay their taxes in Svalbard? Well…
despite
being a Norwegian territory, the Svalbard
treaty forbids to
any country to tax the profits. This means,
their citizens pay
the minimum required to finance their own
governance. In
other words: Svalbard could be considered
as a fiscal
haven. They have no VAT and their corporate
tax raises to
a 16%, which is even lower than Singapore´s.
But make no mistake! All those thai, russians
and
swedish
people are not coming to Svalbard attracted
by the low
taxes, nor the coal mines. As you can imagine,
picking coal
in the North Pole is an expensive and not
profitable
business…
“Svalbard coal mine halts production”
And you will wonder… If coal is not profitable…
Why are
there so many people coming here? Let me remind
you
that, during winter, Svalbard lives a never
ending night
where there is not even a single minute of
daylight.
Of course, some of those men and women work
on the
several science research centres existing
in the
archipielago. Actually, since 2008, Svalbard
has the Global
Seed Vault. An storage pit paid, mainly, by
Bill and Melinda
Gates Foundation and Microsoft. Here they
store a
collection of seeds for all the different
kind of plants that
exist in the world. In case of a nuclear holocaust,
mankind
would be able to replant the planet thanks
to this great
vault. And it´s protected against any kind
of attack.
But this is not the reason why Svalbard is
so important. In
fact, there is something more juicy than coal,
polar bears,
science or Santa Claus himself…
“The Arctic holds an estimated 13% (90 billion
barrels) of
the world&#39;s undiscovered conventional
oil resources and
30% of its undiscovered conventional natural
gas resource”.
Exactly! They have oil! But not only that!
Imagine for a
second that you want to ship some good from
LONDON to
TOKIO. Today, the fastest route would be this
one.
But imagine you could do this using another
route. Do you
see? This is almost half of the distance.
This means less
spending and a faster logistics. Technology
and climate
change are making possible to travel through
Arctic ocean.
And this would be a turning point in the international
trade.
One day, this will be a reality. And that
day, Svalbard has
the highest chances to become the Arctic capital.
The rest
of the islands around belong to Russia and
are have no
human population. Greenland, on the other
hand, has a
chaotic legal system. Meanwhile, Svalbard
has a strong
political system and good infrastructures.
The proof is this
interview to Steve, held through Skype. But
wait a minute
because here it is the best part!
All this Arctic oil is under the sea. This
means, the above-
the-ground land of Svalbard has no oil beds,
at least that
we know it. All their wealth is on the so-called
CONTINENTAL SHELF. This is the underwater
landmass
which extends from a continent no deeper than
200m.
According to the international law, the continental
shelf
belongs to the country it is attached to.
And, of course, it
includes all the resources beneath. So it
should be the
government of a country the one to decide
whether if they
allow companies to exploit this resources
or not.
And yes, both Norway and Svalbard´s archipielago
are on
the same contintental shelf. Therefore, in
normal conditions,
Norwegian Government should have sovereignity
over this
oil.
BUT!!!! Do you remember what it is said on
the Svalbard
Treaty? Every country can exploit the resources
and
Norway can do nothing to stop them.
The problem? Well… that treaty sais nothing
about the
continental shelf or anything under the water.
At the end of
the day, when it was signed, no one would
think about
extracting oil from the bottom of the ocean.
And this is why, news like this one make people
so nervous.
“Russia believes Norway is violating the
Svalbard Treaty
when the Norwegian government opens three
blocks for oil
drilling in the Barents Sea, close to the
Arctic archipelago.”
In summary, Russia sais the continental shelf
of Svalbard
should adjust to the treaty and be exploited
by any country.
But Norway claims that since the legal text
didn´t include
anything about this, the oil and the rights
to extract it
belongs to them.
And… what was Russia´s answer? You might
still think this
North Pole thing is a small story. One of
those things for
academics and diplomats to have discussions
while having
dinner. But the truth is, Vladimir Putin sent
to his VICE
PRIME MINISTER, Dimitry Rogozin, to make a
controversial visit to the archipielago.
But wait! The best is yet to come! This visit
torn Svalbard
into a fashionable tourism destination amont
the russians.
In the last 2 years, the Svalbard tourism
has increased at a
500% rate. As I said from the beginning, there
are two
villages on the main island: the Norwegian
and the Russian,
which is called BARENTSBURG, with a population
lower
than 500 people. Well, just in the year 2015,
they had more
than 60.000 tourists.
And
now you might wonder Why Russian tourism is
that
important in Svalbard? Well, it helps to retain
population.
For
a better understanding, in the Russian settlement
there
is no currency. The mining company takes care
of
everything. Something like this happened on
the Norwegian
settlement too. But then, tourism started
and that brought
new kinds of business
and different people.
Watch out! Here we are talking about oil and
influence in
what might become one of the main sea routes
in the
World. In fact, even China is trying to buy
properties here.
But we will talk about this in another video.
And now we wanna hear your opinion Do you
really think
Svalbard might become a new and frozen Dubai?
Shall
Norway let Russia exploit the Svalbard oil?
You can leave
your answer in the comment section below.
And don´t forget we upload brand new videos
every
Monday and Thursday so don´t forget to Subscribe
to our
channel so you won´t miss any post.
If you like this video, give us a thumbs up.
See you next
time!